c'est l'heure de mardi politique sur
France 24 bonsoir et bonsoir à vous
Patrick mignolin bonsoir vous êtes
vice-président du MoDem merci d'avoir
accepté donc notre invitation alors
forte mobilisation aujourd'hui contre la
réforme des retraites dans les rues de
France qui de la rue ou de l'exécutif va
reculer il y en a forcément un qui va
gagner lequel ce serait bien que ce soit
les Français et donc on parviennent à
faire une réforme des retraites qui leur
conviennent parce que c'est assez normal
légitime qu'un grand nombre de Français
ont envie de se mobiliser soit dans leur
rue disent leur contestation parfois
parfois leurs colères parfois leur
opposition au gouvernement parfois
d'ailleurs peut-être plus au
gouvernement à la réforme elle-même
je crois qu'il faut
il faut 1000 fois remettre l'ouvrage sur
le métier et se dire d'abord que bah oui
il était logique de venir sur une
réforme des retraites ça fait longtemps
que tout le monde en parle et que tout
le monde s'y attendait en 1980 on
partait à la retraite à 65 ans et
désormais envie dix ans de plus et donc
on voit bien que forcément on avait un
problème au moins comptable
et puis à 60 ans à 65 ans en 1980 alors
qu'aujourd'hui on part à la retraite à
62 alors qu'on vit 10 ans de plus donc
on voit bien que à un moment donné il y
a pas besoin d'être grand mathématiciens
pour se rendre compte que forcément il y
avait un problème d'équilibre
alors il y a une chose qu'ils entendent
assez bien je crois
c'est que le système actuel ne
fonctionne pas c'est-à-dire qu'il y a de
grandes injustices pour les métiers
pénibles ça tout le monde le sait il y a
de grandes injustices mais qui sont un
peu comme l'éléphant au milieu du
couloir pour les femmes d'abord parce
que
jusqu'à la réforme de 2012 elles étaient
très maltraitées aujourd'hui elle reste
maltraitées parce que les trimestres de
maternité par exemple sont considérés
comme travailler valider mais non cotisé
et puis tout simplement parce qu'il y a
un énorme écart salarial qui demeure
entre les hommes et les hommes qui a
pointé
un amendement oui parce que tout dire
franchement on aurait pas fait les
choses comme ça et François Bayrou l'a
dit à l'époque on aurait préféré avoir
une réflexion comme le disait Laurent
Berger d'ailleurs on aurait pu se
retrouver là-dessus avec les forces
syndicales porter une réflexion sur le
travail aujourd'hui dans la société
nouveau rapport au travail qui a quand
même énormément évolué depuis une
dizaine d'années et plus encore avec le
moment du covid on a vu à la fois
évidemment le télétravail se développer
mais on a vu aussi toute l'importance
des salariés de première et de deuxième
ligne et la difficulté de rémunération
qui pouvait avoir les enjeux
au travail aussi bien dans le public que
le prix privé lié au logement lié au
mobilité liées à la gare des enfants
finalement on aurait pris des choses à
l'endroit avant de faire de la réforme
de l'assurance chômage puis ensuite la
réforme des retraites peut-être que on
serait pas dans un dans un tel moment de
colère avec avec le pignon public donc
vous êtes en train de me dire que
pardonnez-moi l'expression
cette affaire a été mal embouchée dès le
début je crois que effectivement
quand on fait de la politique il faut
parler de la vision partagée de la
société et il peut y avoir des
désaccords évidemment et puis c'est ça
on démocratie mais on aurait pu prendre
les choses ainsi donc puisque
malheureusement
du travail dans la société des
évolutions de travail et à partir de là
ça aura changé une chose voyez-vous par
exemple sur les carrières longues on dit
aujourd'hui qu'il faut que les gens
partent plutôt s'ils ont une carrière
non ce qui est bien légitime mais ce qui
est un peu le cas dans le régime actuel
déjà
mais on oublie de parler des carrières
hachées il y a des personnes qui n'ont
pas de carrière longue mais qui en
revanche une toute petite retraite parce
que ils ont eu plusieurs difficultés et
je crois qu'il y a rien de mieux dans
une société que donner des deuxième et
des 3e chance mais seulement quand on a
eu des deuxième et des 3e chance mais
parfois faut travailler jusqu'à 66 ou 67
ans quel âge maximum pour avoir une
retraite à taux plein donc il faut
réparer ces injustices avant même de
faire voter cette réforme alors en tout
cas en tout cas ce qu'on s'est dit
à l'Assemblée nationale c'est que
puisque cette réforme était ainsi
présentée et objectivement je conteste
pas la nécessité de devoir faire un
équilibre puisque de toute façon on vit
tous un peu plus longtemps et tant mieux
donc on a tous besoin de travailler un
peu plus longtemps pour pouvoir cotiser
pour la retraite de nos parents et de
nos grands-parents
à qui vous pouvez dire tiens chaque
semaine désormais tu vas travailler 5
heures de plus et dans ta vie tu
travailleras d'autant plus
franchement ça fait partie de la
responsabilité gouvernementale et quel
que soit les couleurs politiques et quel
que soit les gouvernements qui au
responsabilités aujourd'hui ils auraient
tous regardé les choses c'est il y a les
caisses agir Carco ça concerne près de
10 presque 11 millions de salariés dans
le pays les salariés du privé
ils sont gérés par les syndicats eux ils
étaient à 63 ans et ils sont placés
l'âge de départ à taux plein à 64 ans et
ce sont les syndicats qui l'ont décidé
donc évidemment que ça fait plaisir à
personne mais pour autant il y a une
obligation qui est assez évidente après
il faut il faut chercher les mesures de
justice
et les mesures de justice je crois
vraiment c'est la droite
est-ce que c'est pas le monde à l'envers
parce que vous vous avez proposé
effectivement
l'amendement sur les femmes et leur
carrière justement les femmes ayant eu
des enfants il y a eu l'index Seigneur
qui a été voté hier au Sénat donc c'est
la droite qui a adoucit en quelque sorte
la réforme est-ce que c'est pas vous
parliez d'endroits et en vert est-ce que
c'est pas le monde à l'envers qui est
assez paradoxal c'est que la droite
avait fait la campagne présidentielle
sur le 65 ans pour tous ou presque à
peine adoucie et que désormais c'est
effectivement la droite qui essaye parce
qu'il nous faut trouver une majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale de trouver des des
apports sociaux je dois avouer c'est
sans doute un échec pour le pour ma
famille politique que
nos voix ont été couvertes par les
lépitres et les pupitres de les filles
pendant à peu près tout le débat à
l'Assemblée nationale et c'est très
regrettable l'important c'est qu'à la
fin on y parvienne c'est à dire que pour
la pénibilité pour les carrières longues
pour les femmes et pour l'emploi des
seniors on fasse progresser déjà le
système actuel et donc qui a un
équilibre comptable et qu'on se retrouve
pas avec les mêmes injustices dans le
système de demain parce que je souhaite
que cette réforme soit votée que dans le
système d'aujourd'hui parce que ce que
les Français ignorent avant d'arriver à
la retraite c'est que ce système il est
avant tout injuste en fait alors
justement on parlait des des trop tôt là
pour faire le bilan des manifestations
mais on l'aura ce soir il y a du monde
certes alors la France c'est pas à
l'arrêt elle est un peu elle va on va
dire à un train de sénateur
quand même comment est-ce que c'est ce
que disent les Français une partie des
Français c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont
d'accord du côté des syndicats et à la
fois dans les sondages d'opinion ils
sont persuadés que la réforme va quand
même passer
comme déjà c'est un paradoxe mais
comment est-ce que vous est-ce que le
gouvernement entend suffisamment la rue
c'est ça le sujet aussi je crois que
à la rue qui faut respecter comme aux
élus du suffrage universel qu'il faut
respecter à l'Assemblée nationale et au
Sénat le soleil en ce moment même en
train d'étudier l'article 7 c'est-à-dire
le passage à 63 puis à 64 ans décider à
ce moment-là en 2027
il faut leur dire que il y a encore du
grain à moudre et encore des discussions
à avoir vous savez moi je pense que sur
la question du chômage des seniors on a
quand même jusqu'au 21 mars au cinéma
et le Sénat et puis il y aura un vote
parce que même si le Sénat et
l'Assemblée nationale se mettent
d'accord il faudra retourner à
l'Assemblée nationale on trouve une
majorité pour trouver cette majorité moi
je pense qu'aujourd'hui surtout quand on
arrive comme ça
au cœur de du calendrier au cœur de la
réforme il faut se donner des priorités
et moi je crois que la priorité c'est de
dire que s'il y a une grande injustice
économique dans ce pays c'est la
différence entre les hommes et les
femmes et l'inégalité salariale si cette
réforme peut la compenser un peu et
qu'on parvient dans les cinq à dix ans
qui viennent à enfin rééquilibrer cette
grande injustice on aura fait un grand
pas parce que pour le reste objectif
effectivement les Français partent en
moyenne à 63,4 ans à la retraite donc le
sujet c'est plutôt de lutter contre les
injustices que de savoir si on
travaillera tous 6 mois de plus est-ce
que cette à force de faire et vous avez
raison il faut réparer les injustices
mais à force de faire des concessions
certains disent dans le fond cette
réforme va être
inefficace et elle ne va pas atteindre
ses objectifs c'est-à-dire le fameux
déficit parce que à chaque mesure égale
des millions mais quel est l'objectif
faut se mettre d'accord sur l'objectif
c'est pour ça que je dis qu'on a
peut-être fait deux choses un peu à
l'envers quand même se mettre d'accord
sur l'objectif l'objectif c'est pas de
faire des économies l'objectif c'est
d'équilibrer le système et contrairement
à ce qu'on a beaucoup bien entendu
depuis quelques mois maintenant
le système n'est pas équilibré puisque
l'État participe au de la même de la
retraite des fonctionnaires à
l'équilibre général du système à hauteur
de 20 milliards aujourd'hui maintenant
c'est pas horizon 2032 ou 2035 dès
aujourd'hui c'est déjà le cas donc il
s'agit pas de faire une réforme des
retraites pour retirer de l'argent faire
des économies pour pouvoir le mettre
ailleurs il s'agit d'éviter que le
budget de l'État qui doit aller lui
aussi dans l'hôpital dans l'éducation
dans la cohésion sociale dans
l'aménagement du territoire ne soit pas
obligé de surcompenser les retraites
parce que sinon il y a une chose qui est
très simple est-ce que les Français
d'ailleurs disaient au moment des gilets
jaunes c'est mais qu'est-ce que vous
faites de l'argent oui bah c'est assez
simple il y en a un système social moi
je crois qu'il faut le défendre
je crois que c'est bien d'avoir une
retraite par répartition on aurait
peut-être pu commencer par ça aussi
poser la question en français est-ce que
vous voulez le la retraite par
répartition beaucoup d'entre eux
ignorent encore que quand on paye des
cotisations salariales de retraite
chaque mois on paye pas pour nous c'est
pas de la capitalisation on paye pour
nous parents et nos grands-parents c'est
les actifs qui payent pour les retraités
donc dans une société très
individualiste
c'était peut-être une question qu'il
fallait régler à l'avance moi je suis
favorable à ce système par répartition
parce que c'est comme ça c'est une
mesure de solidarité nationale entre les
plus jeunes et les plus anciens qui ont
travaillé tout ou partie de leur vie les
Français visiblement ne sont pas
d'accord avec cette vision des choses
moi je le regrette et je veux que nous
puissions les convaincre que nos
systèmes de protection sociale est à
défendre et c'est très difficile parce
que là encore c'est comme quand vous
dites aux personnes qui doivent
travailler six mois ou un an de plus
dans leur vie si vous leur dites que ils
doivent cotiser pour leurs parents leurs
grands-parents ils sont pas
nécessairement content mais c'est comme
ça que fonctionne une société mais
objectivement comment comment le
gouvernement va se sortir enfin il
voulait l'exécutive va se sortir de ce
pardonner moi mais du se pétrin
aujourd'hui on voit quand même que les
il y a deux camps déterminés celui du
gouvernement qui a dit on ne lâchera pas
et d'un autre côté les syndicats qui
sont galvanisés par le succès des manifs
et qui sont prêts en découdre donc faut
qu'il y en ait un des deux qui lâche
mais moi je pense que on peut tout à
l'heure vous n'avez pas répondu à ma
question on peut continuer on peut
continuer alors c'est moi je pense que
on aurait besoin d'avoir une autre
relation avec le monde syndical dans
notre pays
alors on a réussi quand même le
gouvernement a réussi à mettre d'accord
la CFDT à la CGT c'est quand même assez
un objectif c'est celui du retrait et en
ce moment il y a des grandes
manifestations en Allemagne pour
négocier les hausses de salaire et les
manifestations dures viol avec de vrai
des accords mais avec un bénéfice à
aller chercher pour les salariés infinés
on n'arrive pas dans ce pays en France
on a et l'inflation mais pas de hausse
de salaire donc vous avez constaté que
les représentants syndicaux sont arrivés
cette histoire pour la première fois à
se mettre d'accord sur des outils dit de
partage de la valeur la participation de
l'intéressement vous avez vu qu'il y a
des entreprises qui ont fait énormément
de bénéfices pendant la crise que il y a
des augmentations qui sont extrêmement
fortes et donc là pour la première fois
on a eu ces outils là mais effectivement
la réforme des retraites fait passer
tout ça sous silence malheureusement moi
je pense qu'il y a autre chose à faire
dans le débat syndical dans notre pays
qu'à se dire toujours qu'on ne peut
gagner que par le retrait moi je pense
qu'on peut gagner par la négociation et
donc puisqu'il y a une obligation
comptable économique budgétaire à devoir
travailler tous 6 mois de plus c'est ça
dont on parle tous six mois de plus moi
s'il faut pour payer la retraite des
plus anciens qui ont travaillé dans
notre société travailler six mois de
plus ils ne veulent pas travailler deux
ans et pourtant vous l'avez relevé vous
même il pense tout ce que ce sera voté
quand même parce que ils pensent que
nécessité à la fin falloir mais c'est
pas parce que nécessité fait loi qu'on
peut pas en plus améliorer le système
aujourd'hui parce que ils ont énormément
fait progresser le texte sur la question
de la pénibilité
je me souviens des
sur la pénibilité sur la pénibilité il y
avait 11 critères de pénibilité qui
était impossible
c'était absolument incompréhensible et
donc à la fin bah les salariés étaient
perdants parce qu'on pouvait pas
appliquer le critères de pénibilité nous
quand on est arrivé au responsabilité en
2017 on les a réduits à quatre critères
et déjà on a pu progresser la CFDT la
première a voulu ajouter trois critères
des trois critères ils sont ajoutés
aujourd'hui et on ne le voit pas et
pourquoi parce que dans notre pays sans
doute
bon on considère que les victoires
doivent total pour que ce soit des
victoires moi je pense que les salariés
ont déjà beaucoup gagné grâce aux
syndicats dans la concertation et
qu'aujourd'hui les politiques peuvent
encore faire quelques pas au Sénat puis
au retour à la dernière question
là-dessus sur le l'issue parlementaire
mais on a envie quand même de demander à
la majorité est-ce qu'il y avait urgence
en pleine inflation en pleine guerre
avec un système français qui qui ne
marche pas on voit l'hôpital est à
genoux l'école on a vu avec ce qui s'est
passé dernièrement que ça voilà qui
avait des trous dans la raquette comme
on dit vraiment des la justice manque de
moyens la police enfin est-ce que
c'était est-ce que c'était la première
des réformes à faire on a réformé
l'école dans le quinquennat précédent on
a augmenté le budget de la justice de 8%
par an chaque année depuis 3 ans
désormais mais c'est extrêmement d'abord
qu'on parle de du travail avant mais là
de la société Maui la justice on a fait
les états généraux de la justice et on
voit exactement quelque chose là il y
avait vraiment quelque chose de moyen
d'être dans un greffe de tribunal
aujourd'hui vous voyez bien qu'il y a
d'abord un problème de moyens il y a un
problème d'organisation il y a un
problème d'informatisation de
numérisation enfin je sais c'est il y a
certains palais de justice qui sont
moins bien équipés que que une PME
beaucoup enfin à chaque fois que
vous avez tout à fait dans un pays
c'est jamais le bon moment de faire une
réforme qui demande des efforts bon on a
préféré en début de quinquennat que la
réforme qui demandait le plus d'efforts
à chacune et à chacun elle soit assumée
courageusement d'habitude il est vrai
que les
les gouvernements refilent la patate
chaude de la réforme à leur successeur
ce qui est vrai ce qui est un invariant
de la politique française j'ai le
sentiment que pour le coup c'est pas
tout à fait le choix du président Macron
mais c'est peut-être pour ça aussi qu'à
la fin même si beaucoup de Français ne
l'aiment pas
c'est peut-être ce qui lui reconnaîtront
comme mérite c'est qu'il aura osé faire
beaucoup de réformes depuis 2017 qui lui
ont coûté beaucoup de popularité mais
il vaut mieux il vaut mieux marquer
l'histoire qu'elle est populaire sur le
moment
d'autant qu'ils se représente pas
exactement mais quand même comment ça va
se terminer cette histoire d'après vous
entre nous
est-ce que entre nous devant
ce texte cet article qui permet de
passer en force va être déployé ou la
droite va voter la situation est assez
simple la majorité n'est qu'une majorité
relative c'est extrêmement simple il y a
251 députés de la majorité
mais c'est une majorité relative pour
qu'elle devienne absolue il faut qu'il y
ait 289 députés qui votent pour cette
réforme donc il faut une quarantaine
d'autres députés
quand on fait l'accélération de la
réforme Touraine les députés socialistes
pour élever
quand on fait une réforme alors qui est
pas tout à fait le programme de Madame
Pécresse qui est beaucoup plus doux que
ce que proposait madame Pécresse il me
semble que les sur les 60 députés
républicains ils pourraient bien en
avoir une quarantaine qui soit cohérent
avec ce qui disait encore sur les
tréteaux pendant la campagne électorale
il y a une année on va voir si dans
notre monde politique un peu bousculé
finalement
les uns et les autres sont atteints
d'amnésie collective ou s'ils peuvent
avoir un peu de cohérence intellect oui
mais vous savez bien que certains jouent
aussi des partitions
personnelles certains peuvent avoir
envie de provoquer une crise de régime
Aurélien Pradier moi je relisais
récemment un des articles qu'il avait
fait dans Les Echos lui il expliquait
que il fallait qu'on passe à 44 voire 45
ans de travail pour équilibrer les
retraites et puis finalement aujourd'hui
nous explique que ça doit être 43 43
pour tous et encore de toute façon même
quand la Première ministre lui accorde
parce qu'il est dans un sans doute un
calcul personnel en disant que ce serait
peut-être la façon de faire tomber le
gouvernement il faut faire autrement
moi je pense que au moment du vote
il faut penser à ces électeurs
éventuellement à ceux qui ont pas voter
pour nous
et un peu moins au calcul politique pour
faire tomber un gouvernement
engueuler dans leur dans leur
circonscriptions
c'est dans les moments où je me suis le
plus fait engueuler que finalement six
ou huit mois après me disait bah
finalement tu avais raison parce que tu
as été courageux la politique c'est
aussi ça c'est pas seulement du calcul
ok merci en tout cas merci beaucoup
Patrick Mignola donc vice-président